let's get back to the phones 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 let's go to Thomas Thomas you are
on what's going on Thomas hello that is
you okay thank you I had a question I
it's about the midterm election okay I I
keep I keep seeing articles about people
sort of downplaying how you know a
Democrats been really sick C or whatever
but I'm just wanting it and if I'm being
Ingrid I'm sorry it's just they managed
to win the majority of a branch of
government while the Republicans only
managed to just gain a couple more
senators in the Senate so is that really
is I really is that really downplayed as
it should be or so listen I think that
there's sort of competing forces there
there's a couple different issues that
are going on here one is that the Senate
was hugely stacked against Democrats
because you had 42 Senate seats that
weren't even up for re-election right so
sort of at the base level the Senate was
stacked against Democrats and you have
to have sort of reasonable expectations
for what's even possible that's number
one
I think that you're completely right
that taking over a branch of government
particularly one that's going to allow
you investigative power for the next few
years one that's going to give you a
stronger foothold for the 2020 election
that is a big deal
picking up seven gubernatorial seats and
Republicans losing seven that's a really
big deal so I agree with you that the
downplaying of the successes for
Democrats of the midterms are wrong I
think what is resonating most with me in
terms of a criticism is that it seems as
though the failings of Trump cartoonish
right-wing ISM and the fact that
Democrats the the party that loses the
White House tends to do well in the next
midterms are responsible for a lot of
what we saw and when I sit back and I
say this has been the most embarrassing
two years of a
administration in a very long time only
doing this feels kind of like this is
this is all we get after such an
atrocious
two years should we have gotten more and
I think that there's something to that
and then we get to well our Democrats is
the messaging of Democrats right are
they taking the right position so I
think that there are lots of criticisms
but the winds are significant as you
point out yeah they think now that you
mentioned I think they were correct in
saying like you know blue laid didn't
really happen but like a lot did happen
for Democrats a lot how that like
sweetpea
that's not like sweeping as we hoped
would so thank you for taking your time
to call me on all right yeah Thomas
thank you for the call always great to
hear from you